about
six months into my career as a therapist
i was working at a drug and alcohol
rehab facility
i got a call from one of the nurses down
the detox unit
she asked me to come down and assess one
of the new patients that had arrived
earlier in the day
so i went down to the unit had the
pleasure of being hand
and's a transgender female and as her
and i started talking she would share
with me about what
brought her into treatment but i could
hear this fear in her voice
and i could see this worry in her eyes
and she began to tell me that she didn't
fear coming into rehab and having to
give up drugs and alcohol
her fear was that the doctors that were
going to be treating her would not treat
her as her female self
she then told me about this ongoing pain
that she has experienced her whole life
of being assigned
male but knowing she's female and what
she meant by that is when she was born
the doctor held her up to her parents
and based on her genitalia said
it's a boy she always knew she wasn't a
boy many years pass
and the feelings that she was feeling
and and holding all this in grew and
grew and she knew she had to come out to
her family
and when she did it didn't go over so
well her parents said
absolutely not you're not a girl this is
not how we raised you we don't know what
you're thinking
get out so ann then found herself in the
streets and
in and out of homeless shelters and it's
here where she started using drugs and
alcohol to numb this pain she fell
inside
she told me about her journey of being
in and out of hospitals and rehabs
trying to get sober and
when she did the health care providers
and doctors wouldn't use the correct
female name or pronouns
this caused her pain you see
when i was studying to become a
therapist i wasn't taught how to work
with transgender patients
i had no idea this would be the patients
i'd be working with
but the more i worked with ann and other
patients like in
i began to see my mission evolve and
that was to make sure that the
transgender
community got their health care needs
met
the more i looked into this i saw how
this
very real fear of violence
discrimination and his lack of
acceptance
caused so many of these patients to turn
to alcohol and drugs
and i also heard these horror stories of
when these patients were seeking medical
care
and how they were treated and how a lot
of their medical needs were ignored
now let me tell you about leah i had the
pleasure meeting lee a few years back
she's a female and she has a wife and a
child
see leah was also assigned male at birth
and she knew
since she was a young child that she was
not a male that she was a female
she hid it from herself and from
everyone she knew
especially from her wife until the age
of 50 she couldn't take it anymore
she's like i can't keep living like this
i got to get honest she was extremely
scared to tell her wife
what if her wife said this is
unacceptable i want to divorce
get out to her surprise her wife was
accepting
she said i love you regardless of who
you are i want to help you in every way
i can
so she talked with her wife and she made
the decision that
she wanted to medically transition and
she was interested in being assessed for
hormone replacement therapy otherwise
known as hrt
so she made an appointment with her
doctor
she arrived on the day of her
appointment early she found out all the
paperwork
put the name correctly down there and
waited patiently
a little bit of time passed and the
nurse called her back to the exam room
when she got back there she took a deep
breath and the doctor the nurse walked
in
she extended her hand to the doctor said
hi i'm leah
the doctor looked at her didn't shake
her hand and said
why are you here she took another deep
breath and said
well i'm a transgender female i've known
this my whole life i've hid it from
everyone but i can't do it anymore
my wife's supportive i can financially
afford it
i've got to make these changes please
consider me and let's evaluate me for
hrt the doctor said we can't do anything
today you need to go get a hiv test
she couldn't believe it she was furious
she was angry she was disappointed if
her doctor treated her this way
how would the rest of the world treat
her first he wouldn't shake her hand
and second when he heard she was
transgender
all he cared about was getting hiv test
and into the appointment he didn't even
ask her any of the questions
see i can understand where lee is coming
from because
the years that i work with community i
hear myths every single day that aren't
true at all a couple of those are
every transgender person wants to
transition with medication or surgery
transgender people are mentally ill this
is a disorder and
these people aren't real men and women
these are all myths and untrue
as this community expands and grows
older it is imperative that all health
care providers be trained
on how to take care of their health care
needs back in 2015
a survey was done and found that 72
percent of health care providers
did not feel well informed on the health
care needs of the lgbt community
there's a huge gap in the education and
training
today in this talk i want to offer a new
way of thinking for three groups of
people
doctors the transgender community and
well the rest of us
but before we do i want to cover a
couple of definitions that's going to
help you wrap your head around
gender identity a little bit more so i
hope you've got your paper and pen
get ready to take some notes so let's
start out with this idea of a binary
system
and what this means is before we always
thought there was only two
male and female get it binary right so
we've come to find out that
this isn't true gender identity is a
spectrum
with maleness on one side and femaleness
over here on the other side this
spectrum of identities
include identities such as gender
non-conforming
gender affirming gender non-binary
two-spirited three-spirit
as well as people that are intersex the
term transgender is this
umbrella term that encompasses all these
different types of
identities but for today's talk i want
you to think about transgender as
someone who is assigned a sex at birth
that doesn't match with who they are as
a person in their sense of self
now this is very different than
biological sex so gender identity is
sense of self so think of it
as what's between your ears sense of
self who you are
this is very different than biological
sex right hormones genitalia chromosomes
that's what's between our legs
now you may be thinking dr christie i
have never questioned who i am
i know i'm a man or i know i'm a woman i
get it
you know who you are this is how many
transgender individuals feel
they just know who they are with that
same
conviction it's important to know there
are many different types of identities
and i
identify as a cis gender female now for
all y'all out there that likes to know
how to spell things
cis is spelled cis it's
latin term for on the same side of when
i was born
the doctor held me up to my parents and
said it's a girl all this based on my
genitalia
even though i grew up in a small farm
town in georgia very much a farm
very much a tomboy i never questioned
that i was a female i've always known i
was a girl
regardless of how i was as a kid now
this is very different than someone
who's
transgender now trans is a latin term
for on the other side of
think about transcontinental airlines
across on the other side of
someone's that's assigned a sext at
birth
and they identify on the other side of
the spectrum
a transgender male is someone who is
assigned female at birth
but their sense of self who they are how
they live their life
is as a male and the opposite is as we
talked earlier transgender female
someone's assigned male at birth but
lives their life and sense of self
as a female it's also important to point
out here that not everyone that has a
non-binary identity
identifies with the term transgender
just so nobody gets confused i want to
point out sexual identity or orientation
that is simply who we're attracted to
physically emotionally sexually
spiritually
it's got nothing to do with gender
identity so just for a quick recap
before we continue on
gender identity between the ears
biological sex just think of it between
your legs
and then sexual identity well sometimes
we use our heart but it's here
right three very different identity
spectrums
now the average medical student spends
about five hours
learning about the lgbt health related
needs while they're in medical school
now this is despite us knowing there are
unique health
risks to this community
and there's an estimated 10 million
american adults that identify as lgbt
most doctors that work with transgender
patients they learn
trial by fire that means they figure it
out as they go along
or the patient ends up spending their
time trying to teach the doctor
how to take care of them many doctors
don't feel comfortable asking about
gender
identity some don't feel like it's
relevant at all to their medical care
and others just don't want to say the
wrong thing
many doctors who say something
inappropriate or they say something
negative
they may not be coming from a malicious
or mean place
they may have never been trained on how
to care for these individuals
but this can't be accepted as a norm
anymore either
so what happens to a transgender male
for a quick recap that's someone who's
assigned female at birth but lives their
life as a male
what happens when this transgender male
goes for the yearly
gynecological visit
how that doctor treats that patient will
set the whole
tone for the office if that doctor
treats
that male with the correct pronouns
correct name gives dignity and respect
it's highly likely that the rest of the
staff will too
so that's a little bit about my thoughts
on doctors and let's move on to the
transgender community
i'm here talking about fear but y'all
know who's really fearful right
it's a transgender community earlier i
shared the story about anne and how she
was so worried about going into
treatment not being respected as her
female self and then
leah who was scared of how her doctor
would react and the second that he
didn't shake her hand and order that hiv
test
her fears came true the transgender
community
needs to be empowered to speak up for
their health care needs
the days of remaining silent and taking
whatever treatment you can get are over
if you don't speak up for your health
care needs no one's going to do it for
you
so what about the rest of us a lot of
y'all
maybe in the next week or a couple of
months are going to have a doctor
appointment right
so let's say you go to your doctor's
appointment when it's over
you feel worse than you did when you got
there
what if you felt dismissed by the doctor
that they ignored your needs or
you even felt judged
that's what happens for many of the 1.4
million transgender adults
here in the u.s if they're lucky enough
to get an appointment
now you may be thinking why is this
important to me i don't i'm not
transgender i don't know anybody's
transgender
why i shouldn't even care think of it
this way
a transgender individual is human just
like you and me
they deserve competent and trained
health care providers just like you and
me
so let me ask if you don't mind raising
your hand do you
know or have you met anyone who is
transgender gender non-conforming
agender intersex two-spirited
three-spirited
thank you all so much lovely thank y'all
every one of y'all who did not raise
your hand in the very near
future you will get the opportunity to
meet someone that falls into one of
these identities i guarantee it
the number of this community is
increasing
that's not because it's a fad or the new
thing to do
it's safer to come out there's more
awareness there's more visibility
there's more safety so people are
speaking up about their true self like
never before
that's why it's so important that our
health care system get on board
and make sure that our doctors and
health care providers are trained
to approach these patients with dignity
and respect
just like we expect
i remember being in my 11th grade
literature class with one of my favorite
teachers mr mclean and
he shared this quote by heraclitus that
sticks with me to this day
y'all may have even heard it it's the
only thing that is constant
is that things will change
familiar right every single one of us
face changes in our lives and often
we're faced with these changes we got
some difficult decisions to make
will we remain in fear stay stuck
and not grow or will we
face fear with bravery evolve
take the opportunity to grow
every one of us face new things what
will you do
will you remain in fear or
will you grow i invite each of you
doctors the transgender community and
you and i
to face fear together as we walk into
this brave new world
thank you